we've already talked about how dna's
structure as this double helix this
twisted ladder makes it suitable for
being the molecular basis of heredity
and what we want to do in this video is
get a better appreciation for why it is
suitable and the mechanism by which it
is the molecular basis for heredity and
we're going to focus on a conceptual
level i'm not going to go into all of
the i guess you could say biochemical
details really just give you the
conceptual idea of what happens
so right over here this could be a
fragment of dna i have what i have this
is eight base pairs depicted and just to
be clear we talked about this in the
introductory video to dna dna is a
is much more than you know a handful of
base pairs the dna molecule can be
tens of millions of base pairs long so
for example this might be a section of a
much longer molecule so
the much longer
strand of dna and i even there i'm
probably not not giving justice to it
but this might just be
this very
very small section right let me just in
a different color
this little section right over here
zoomed in
so once again it might be part of a
molecule that has not 7
or eight base pairs but might have 70
million base pairs
so
just like that
so just like that
so let's understand what a molecular
basis of heredity would need to do well
first of all it would need to be
replicable or needed or something
we would need to be able to replicate it
as a cell divides the the the two
new cells would want to have the same
genetic material so how does dna
replicate and this process is called
replication
so let me
replication and we covered this in the
introduction video as well but it's nice
to see the different processes
next to each other
and replication
well you can imagine taking either both
splitting these two sides of the ladder
and actually let's do that
so let me copy and paste
so if i take that side
right over there
and so let me copy and then paste it
and then
there we go a little bit of it is
dropping below
the video but i think that serves the
purpose and then
and then let's copy and paste the other
side
so
let me
select that
and then i copy and then i paste
and it's just like that
and so you can imagine
if you were to split these
these i guess you could call them two
sides of the ladder then either side
could be used to construct the other
side and then you would have two strands
two identical strands of the dna and so
let's let's see what that actually looks
like so let me get my pen tool out now
let me deselect this
and get the pen tool out to be
it's a new tool i'm using so let me make
sure i'm doing it right all right so
from this side from this left side or at
least what we are looking at is the left
side you can then construct another
right side based on this information a
always
always pairs with t if we're talking
about dna so so adenine pairs with
thymine just like that thymine pairs
with adenine
let me do that a little bit neater
thymine pairs with
adenine guanine pairs with cytosine
with cytosine cytosine pairs with
guanine falling a little bit down here
and just like that i was able to
construct a new right hand side using
that left hand side
so maybe i'll do the the
the new
sugar phosphate backbone in yellow and
we can do the same thing here using the
original right hand side so using the
original right hand side once again
the t's pair with the a's thyme let me
do that in that adenine's color
so we have an adenine and thymine
adenine and thymine adenine and thymine
thymine pairs with adenine so thymine
adenine
thymine adenine guanine pairs with
cytosine
guanine
guanine and then cytosine pairs with
so
cytosine just like that
and so you can take half of each of this
ladder and then you could use it to
construct the other half and what you've
essentially done is you've you've
replicated the actual dna and this is
actually a kind of conceptual level of
how replication is done before a cell
divides and replicates and the entire
cell duplicates itself so that's
replication
so the next thing you're probably
thinking about okay well you know it's
nice to be able to replicate yourself
but that's kind of useless if that
information can't be used to to define
the organism in some way to to express
what's actually happening and so let's
think about how
how the the the genes in this this this
dna molecule are actually expressed
so
i'll write this as expression
expression and actually that actually
warrants a a little bit of a of a detour
because you hear sometimes the words dna
and chromosome and gene used somewhat
interchangeably and they are clearly
related but it's worth knowing what what
is what so when you're talking about dna
you're talking literally about this
molecule here that has this sugar
phosphate base and it has these the
sequence of base pairs it's got this
double helix structure and so this whole
thing this could be a dna molecule now
when you when you have a dna molecule
it's packaged together with other
molecules and proteins and kind of given
a broader structure than you're talking
about then you're talking about a
chromosome and when you're talking about
a gene you're talking about a section of
dna that's used to express a certain
trait or actually used to code for a
certain type of protein so for example
this could be this this whole thing
could be a strand of dna but this part
right over let's say an orange i'll do
it this part in orange right over here
could be one gene it might define it it
could this information for one gene it
could define a protein this one might
this section right over here could do
could be used to define another gene and
genes could be anywhere from several
thousand base pairs long all the way up
into the millions and as we'll see the
ways the way that a gene is expressed
the way we get from the information for
that section of dna into a protein which
is really how it's expressed is through
a related molecule to dna and that is
rna and actually let me write this down
rna
r
and a
so rna stands for ribonucleic acid
ribonucleic acid let me write that down
ribo
nucleic
nucleic acid
and so you might remember that dna is
deoxyribonucleic acid so the sugar
backbone in rna is a very similar
molecule well now it's got its oxy it's
not it's not deoxyribonucleic acid it's
ribonucleic acid the r let me make it
clear where the rna comes from the r is
right over there then you have the
nucleic that's the n it's found or
well it's
nucleic and then it's a acid same reason
why we called the dna nucleic acid so
you have this
rna so what what role does this play as
we are trying to express the information
in this dna
well the dna especially if we're talking
about cells with with nuclei
the dna sits there but it has to that
information has to for the most part get
outside of the nucleus in order to be
expressed and one of the functions that
rna plays is to be that messenger that
messenger between a certain section of
dna and kind of what goes on outside of
the nucleus so that that can be
translated into an actual protein so the
step that you go from dna to mrna
messenger rna is called transcription
let me write that down
transcription
transcription and what happens in
transcription let's go back to looking
at one side of this one side of this dna
molecule
so
let's say you have that right over there
let me copy
and paste it
so
there we go actually i didn't want to do
that
i wanted the other side
so actually i think i'm on the wrong
let me go back here
and so let me
copy
and then let me paste
there we go
so let's say you have
let's say that you have part of this dna
molecule
or you have one half of it just like we
did when we replicated it but now we're
not just trying to we're not just trying
to duplicate the dna molecule we're
actually trying to create a
corresponding mrna molecule at least for
that section that section of for at
least for that gene so this might be
part of a gene that actually whoops let
me make sure i'm using the right tool
this might be part of a gene that is you
know this section of our dna molecule
right over there and so transcription is
a very similar conceptual idea where
we're now going to construct a strand of
rna and specifically mrna because it's
going to take that information outside
of the nucleus
and so it's very similar except for when
we're talking about rna adenine instead
of pairing with thymine is now going to
pair with uracil
so
let me write this down so now you're
going to have adenine pairs not with
thymine but uracil dna has uracil
instead of the thymine but you're still
going to have cytosine and guanine
pairing so for the rna
and in this case the mrna that's going
to leave the nucleus
a is going to pair with u
u for uracil
so uracil uracil that's the base we're
talking about let me write it down
uracil
thymine is still going to pair with
adenine
it's still going to pair with adenine
just like that guanine is going to pair
with cytosine
guanine
and cytosine and cytosine is going to
pair cytosine is going to pair
with guanine and so when you do that now
these two characters can detach and now
you have a single strand of rna and in
this case messenger rna that can that
can that that has all the information on
that section of on that section of a dna
and so now that thing can leave the
nucleus go attached to a ribosome and
we'll talk more about that in in future
videos exactly how that's happened and
then this code can be used to actually
code for proteins now how does that
happen and that process is called
translation
so translation
translation which is really taking this
base pair sequence and turning it into
an amino acid sequence proteins are made
up of sequences of amino acids
so translation so let's take our mrna or
this little section of our mrna
and actually let me do it let me draw it
like this
let me draw it like this and let's see i
have it is uac so it's going to be u a c
then u
u then a c g okay and then we have
an a let me make sure i change to the
right color
we have an a there
and then we have this u u a
cg all right now let me put
a c right over there i'm just taking
this and i'm writing it horizontally i
have a c here
not a g it's a c
and then finally i have a g
and of course it'll keep going on and on
and on and what happens is
each
each sequence of three and you have to
be very careful where it starts and so
this is in some ways a delicate and
surprising but at the same time
surprisingly robust process
every three of these bases
code for a specific amino acid and so
three bases together so these bases
right over here these these i guess you
could say this three-letter word or this
three-letter sequence that's called a
codon codon and this is going to be the
next codon
the next codon and we actually haven't
drawn the next codon after that because
we need three
bases to get to the next codon
and how many possible codons do you have
well you have one of four bases and you
have them in three different places so
you have four times four times four
possible
codon words i guess you could say and
four times four times four is 64. so you
have 64
possible
codons which is good because you have 20
possible amino acids so this is overkill
and allows codons to be used for other
purposes as well and they also you know
you might have more than one codon
coding for the same amino acid so you
have 64 possible codons they need to
code for 20 amino acids and so this
codon right over here
with the ribosome and we'll talk more
about how that happens
can code 4
can code for say
good code for
amino acid one
so let me just write it here this is
amino
acid one and actually this amino acid is
brought to here they're actually matched
together by another type of rna this is
mrna we're talking about right over here
this is m
rna
but there's another type of rna called
trna that essentially that essentially
brings these two characters together so
the trna and i'm just gonna you know
it's got some structure here i'm not
drawing it completely right but it's
going to match right over here where
maybe it has
it has an a
a u
and a g right over here and on this end
it was attached to this amino acid and
so it matches them together and then
they're going to have another
another trna
that might attach to amino acid 2
which i will do in purple
amino acid two and that just happens to
coincide with so it can complement right
over here so it attaches in the right
place so it's a
a u right over here this trna and so
it'll construct the sequence of amino
acids and as you put these amino acids
together then you are actually
constructing a protein so protein is a
is a essentially a bunch of a sequence
of these amino acids put together
so a sequence of these amino acids put
together and these proteins are
essentially the the molecules that that
do that run life for the most part
obviously you know if you eat an animal
it's going to be made up of fat and
sugars and proteins but the proteins are
the things that actually do a lot of the
whether they're enzymes whether they're
structural the muscle is formed from
proteins these are the things and i'm
just drawing a small segment of them
they could be thousands or or more of
these of these amino acids long
and they kind of
form these incredibly complex shapes and
they have all of these functions this is
what's kind of doing the work of life
and this for the most part and this is
how this is kind of how the information
for life is stored